hey what is up guys I'm kid Bhd here
finally finally the new Mac Pro it's
been so long since Apple really updated
their highest end desktop that I made
videos about it got tired of waiting and
then I eventually settled for building
my own in the form of the hackintosh Pro
project but now that it's finally
happened now that Apple's return to
their pro line up one more time for a
massive overhaul of this desktop well I
kind of have to try it out and give it a
shot so this is it
now I actually waited for my custom
order to come in so this is not a base
model this one is the 8 core model which
actually believe is probably the best
choice I can get right now and I'll get
more into that in another video but this
is so this is the 8 core z9e 5 at 3
gigahertz and it's fully loaded
basically with dual d700 graphics cards
a terabyte of flash storage and 64 gigs
of RAM now the unboxing of the Mac Pro
really is super simple in fact Apple
already details everything in the box on
their site already but so many people on
Twitter asked me to do something with
the Mac Pro when I get it so this is for
you guys I love of course more in-depth
coverage of it soon but in the box of
course you get this top piece of
styrofoam which reveals the top of the
computer wrapped in plastic and you can
remove it using basically the top of it
as a handle and yes it is as heavy as
everyone says if you watch other
unboxings of it on YouTube it is quite
heavy weighs in at 11 pounds now deeper
in the box you actually get the power
cable that plugs directly into the back
of the Mac Pro which obviously means the
power supply is completely internal no
power brick and of course you get your
typical Apple documentation with your
you know product decal and actually it
comes with a pair of black Apple
stickers it's actually the only product
to ship with these random fun fact so
that is it that's everything that comes
in the box as you can probably already
tell by Apple's site but since we're
doing an unboxing here's a little
something you won't get on Apple site
might as well show it this is the best
part of unboxing a Mac Pro
now after taking the plastic off it's
actually a lot shinier than I imagined
probably because on Apple site it looks
like this black but in person it looks
like this more gray a sort of a dark
titanium color interesting now before
you make a trashcan joke because I'm
sure some of you haven't gotten this far
in the video and already have yet it
resembles a waste paper basket
everyone thinks they're hilarious making
these jokes but I actually found a trash
can on Amazon that actually already
looks exactly like the Mac Pro so I'll
link that below in case you want to
trick your friends or something with it
but honestly there are a ton more
interesting design choices going on here
besides the fact that the outside of it
resembles well a cylinder and these
things are what I want to talk about in
the full review the fact that it's
incredibly small and compact the fact
that thermally this machine is basically
a miracle the fact that it's very
upgradable but not very expandable and
that there's a huge difference between
those two words this is the only Mac
that lets you upgrade the CPU but so you
can upgrade the RAM and the graphics and
storage and everything but you can't add
anything internally expansion is all
external but for now I'll sign out just
by showing you guys how actually
beautiful such a technically complex
device can be I'm a fan of Technology I
mean I'm sure a lot of you guys are too
but really no matter what you think of
the Mac Pro as a machine you gotta admit
that is a hell of a good-looking machine
can't wait to get started testing and
using all these components either way
let me know what you guys are thinking
let me know the cool stuff you want to
see me do with the Mac Pro on video
maybe there's some comparisons you want
to see feel free to drop those in the
comments section right below that like
button thank you for watching and I'll
talk to you guys in the next one peace
member